Giada, what are we making?
Yes, you ready?
Yes, I am!
We are making Salmon Puttanesca
which is a traditional seafood dish.
A lot of times it's made with tuna,
but instead of making it with tuna today,
we're going to make it with salmon.
So fresh salmon that we've cubed.
So you have a skillet, Drew, with some olive oil in it?
I do. And it seems like
it's a really good temperature right now,
and also Kim, Julie, and Precious are incredible BFFs
who have joined us for Cookbook today.
They all made this dish ahead of time-
Oh good!
and they might have some questions
to pop in here and there, Giada-
Oh amazing!
if that's okay.
Oh, I love it. Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Giada, I made this-
Giada, I do have a question about the fish.
Sure.
I'm severely allergic to shellfish
and I noticed this recipe was done with salmon,
but I wondered if any other proteins
could be substituted as well.
Good question.
Oh, great question. Yeah, yeah. You can use chicken
if you don't want to use any kind of seafood.
It really works with any protein. It's kind of up to you.
Do you want- you ready to throw the pasta in?
I am!
This is a pretty quick-
I am ready ready, Giada.
I'm so-
ready.
And I've got my pasta right here.
Did you salt your water?
No, and I now know, I also learned, you know,
what a cardinal no-no it is to put olive oil in the pasta.
No olive oil in the pasta. You're ruining it.
So once you get the salmon kind of cooking-
Yep.
you can add the red onion and the garlic.
Giada, I have a question.
Sure.
If I did not have red onion,
could I substitute a shallot or something else?
Good question.
Absolutely, you can definitely use shallots.
You can use a regular brown onion or white onion.
Really, any of it.
It's just to give it a little extra flair.
Yeah, it smells really good, and it's a really quick dinner.
So once you've added the onion and the garlic,
you guys ready to add tomatoes?
Yep.
(crowd cheers)
So I've got some cherry tomatoes that I just have.
So we're going to create this really light sort of-
think Amalfi coast, think really light tomato sauce
like from fresh tomatoes.
So now the tomatoes are breaking down
hopefully for everybody, are they?
Yep. Absolutely.
Yeah?
They're looking really, really, really good.
Are you ready to add a little bit of wine?
We're not going to add a lot of wine.
Just a little hint to give it extra flavor.
And that's the great thing about these recipes.
It's not that I've taken everything out of it.
I've just reduced the amounts a little bit
so you get the enhancement of that flavor from the wine.
There we go. It adds a little acidity to the tomatoes
which creates a really well balanced sauce in the end.
So a little bit of white wine.
Giada, I have a question as you're stirring your pasta.
I noticed that you suggested
that gluten-free pasta could be used as well,
but what about a plant-based pasta? Like a chickpea pasta?
Good question.
Sure! If you like chickpea pasta, that'd be great.
Lentil pasta is really great.
There's edamame pastas now that work really well as well.
Okay, thank you.
You guys ready to add some olives?
I just added my olives.
We're also going to add the parsley, the chopped parsley-
Got it.
and the oregano. So again reinforcing-
Giada, I have a question.
Yeah, sure.
So I'm not big on olives. I didn't add that many,
so does that compromise the flavor of the dish at all?
No. You, you can reduce the olives
if you don't like the olives.
It's just this is a traditional dish
that has that flavor component of the rich olives
that salty rich olive
with the light vibrant flavor of tomato.
But you could use capers or use less. Yeah, yeah.
Sounds good. Thank you!
Yeah, yeah. I don't want to forget about my pasta here.
Did you taste your pasta?
Almost.
I missed my mouth on that one.
Be careful cause it's hot.
Now, Giada, my pasta is ready.
Can I add it straight into the bowl-
Let's go! or do I want to drain it?
Yep.
No, I just take this nifty little pasta scooper.
This colander that's like a spoon,
and I add it right into the pan.
The whole idea here is
that you save the pasta water real hot.
So you don't drain it.
You throw the pastor right into the skillet.
Oops.
So that way it can start to absorb,
finish cooking in the sauce
and absorb the flavor of the sauce.
And we're going to add a little bit of pasta water.
Giada, I have a question.
And the pasta water amount depends.
Yeah, go ahead.
So I wasn't sure about the consistency
that the pasta sauce should be.
So how much pasta water should be used?
Well, I would say that you can use anywhere
from a couple tablespoons to a half a cup.
So it kind of depends, but you want it to be saucy.
So I just use two ladlefuls.
So that's going to be, well, I used one ladleful.
So that's gonna be about a quarter cup.
So I might use one more, so up to half a cup.
Yep. I wouldn't use more than a half a cup.
You shouldn't need to.
And then I finish it with a little bit of Parmesan cheese.
Parmigiano.
Looks wonderful.
Parmigiano! And allow the cheese to slowly get mixed in
and just take it easy and just kind of fold it all together.
And as you can see, it should smell really good.
Does it smell good?
It smells so-
good. It's insane.
Yeah. Very sweet, you guys.
This was so fun. Is it taste good?
Oh my god, it's so good!
(crowd cheers)
Oh my gosh, it's so good.
Mmm!
It's delicious you guys.
Now, Kim,
what was one of your favorite things
about making this dish?
That it was quick and it was easy
and it was one pot except for, you know,
boiling the pasta.
The pasta.
That's exactly right.
Didn't dirty up a whole lot of dishes.
Yeah. And that's makes a huge difference.
Julie, what about you?
It was perfect. I worked full time. I'm busy.
It was perfect for a week night meal.
It also has such a clean, beautiful light taste about it.
Precious, what was your favorite part?
Yeah, I would say that taste, the freshness of the dish
because coming out of winter
I was eating so many heavy things
that this was just perfect for a spring evening.
And I love it. It's so fresh and delicious and light.
I'm shoveling it in my mouth.
Yay!
(crowd laughs)
That makes me happy.
Giada, I can't stop. Hold on, I'm like-
It's really fabulous.
I'm so happy.
That makes my day.
I cannot thank you enough. You're just so amazing, Giada
I'm so excited and thrilled that we could
do Cookbook Club with you.
It is so meaningful.
Me too! Thank you for picking me.
Oh, thank you for doing it!
And Kim and Julie and Precious, it is so wonderful
to go on this journey with you,
and don't forget to get your copy of Giada's new book.
It's dropping, it's available right now.
Get it while it's hot.
And then, if you want to make this recipe for
the delicious Puttanesca at home
and you can send it to our website.
Go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and don't forget to join our Cookbook chit chat-
say that five times fast- (crowd laughs)
on social media using #DrewsCookbookClub.
What an honor. Oh, thank you, Giada! Thank you so much.
Thanks ladies!
(bright upbeat music)